في اليابان منذ أكثر من ألف عام
لقد كررت صنع الأشياء بالآلات
قبل العام السابق ، كان استخدام الكستليت أمرًا صعبًا للغاية.
قدر الإمكان عن طريق الجمع بين الخشب والخشب دون استخدام Yue
لقد صنع
لتكرار هذا النوع من الأشياء
إنه موجة تعانق مجنون ، حسنًا
[موسيقى]
اسمي تاك ماتسوموتو
إنه باني نجار القصر
لا استطيع الرؤية
وظيفتي هي بناء وإصلاح المباني في الأضرحة والمعابد اليابانية.
[موسيقى]
المباني الخشبية اليابانية
نظرًا لأنه مصنوع بعناية ، يرجى استخدام التركيبات والبلد.
إنها مسألة تسليم أربعة أفواه ، وصنعها بواسطة حرفي ، ودمجها في بناء مبنى.
يتراوح عمر الأشجار بين 150 و 200 عام
سيكون المبنى نفسه معيبًا
أحيانًا تتعفن ، وأحيانًا تتعطل ، وعندما تواجه كارثة
اعتقد الناس في الأيام الخوالي أن الوقت قد حان لتفكيك وإصلاحه.
فكر في
القصة الرئيسية
من أجل التخرج من المدرسة الإعدادية وقت الولادة وتصبح حرفي نجار
ذهبت إلى Sirio في البداية
لأنني كنت أتساءل كيف تم بناء الأضرحة والمعابد
البداية
هناك عالم مختلف تمامًا عن تقنيتنا الخاصة التي أنشأها أشخاص في المنطقة تسمى Miya carpenter.
إعلم أن
هناك أوقات يكون فيها من الضروري أن يكون لديك فترة مهارة متقدمة ، لكن الأجداد هناك
لأن هناك مبنى خلفه
بينما نتعلم كما نحن الآن
ما ورثه أسلاف الضفدع
ماذا يريد الشعب الياباني أن يفعل
لأنك تستطيع أن ترى ذلك
[موسيقى]
4 دقائق
أنا دائما أذهب إلى الضريح
أذهب للرقص ، لذلك أشعر أنني محمي من الله وبوذا.
أقول إنني أخدم مثل هذا الإله فقط
مثل الدعم العقلي
أنا فخور بأنه يعمل بشكل جيد للغاية.
[موسيقى]
مبنى قديم
يجب أن أعتني به جيدًا
ماذا فعل أسلافنا؟
تعلمنا من ذلك ما نستجيب له دائمًا
اذهب
الدقائق